a movie called the debt that's not about
the financial peril of the US government
that's that's cool the debt now going
into this movie I didn't know anything
about it it could have been about
anything but the debt starts out with
Helen Mirren Tom Wilkinson and that guy
who played Julius Caesar in Rome it
takes place in 1997 you can tell they
all know each other and some of them
have like friction between each other
but they're all these war heroes and
someone wrote a book and it's all great
then the movie flashes back thirty years
prior where they're looking for this
Nazi war criminal and it kind of shows
how they became these war heroes so 30
years prior Helen Mirren's played by
this really she's a hot chick I don't
know who she is but she's hot I've seen
her somewhere before
guys Julius Caesar from ROMs played by
Sam Worthington and Tom Wilkinsons
played by some dude but I suck with
faces that's just me and you're watching
moving you're like all right it's
interesting enough it's kind of
realistic special-ops kind of stuff I
like that because in realistic
special-ops like this things don't
always go according to plan and when it
turns to you're now in a
situation and they were initiate
situation like you know a movie where
people try to pull off a job another
stuck with this prisoner and they don't
know what to do with them that's kind of
this movie and there's this really cool
twist in the movie I can't really tell
you about it because it will ruin the
movie but when you see it you're like oh
holy look at that and then you
start thinking yourself what would you
do in this kind of situation it has this
really cool moral dilemma on it and I
like that no moral relativism so it's
kind of what keeps the world spinning I
wish the world spun on puppy's rainbows
Christmas and you know candy and all
that good stuff but in the end it is
moral relativism now I like the
characters in this movie Helen Mary I
liked her character although is Helen
Mirren she could play anything and I'll
be like she's a great actress and I
liked her character she did a good job
as the Green River Killer Sam
Worthington character is kind of funny
for me because he plays this really
stoic emotionless agent which is pretty
much Sam Worthington in 9/10 of his
movies all four of them which the math
makes sense somehow somewhere but I
can't tell you much about this movie
without ruining it but in the end I like
the characters I like the acting I like
the premise I like the moral dilemma in
the movie that makes you go dude what
would I do in that situation I will say
it's a good time no alcohol required the
movie kind of felt like Munich but you
know one tenth the length because Munich
felt long this movie's a two-hour drama
as a two-hour drama I would watch it
again for the sake of being like hey
friend of mine to watch this movie I'll
watch it with you I would be down for
watching this movie again for sure but I
don't know that I'd be sitting on my
couch alone being like you know what I'm
gonna grab myself a cold one I'm gonna
watch the dead alone but it's worth
watching a walk out of the movie going
you know what it was well done it was
good so even though it's still summer is
September now so
I feel like this is a fall movie now it
looks like the fall movies are gonna
surprise me for the most part and the
podcast I did with the schmoes from
schmoes know in which they interview me
is up now put the links below go check
them out it's a podcast in which they
interview me about me you know how I got
into YouTube all that good stuff it's
like a Jeremy behind the scenes kind of
thing so it's good to listen to if
you're like cleaning your house driving
staring at your computer doing nothing
really in any case if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more